I have Nick Gillespie of Reason TV today
we're talking with former recent intern
Jeremy lot the author of a new book
called William F Buckley in the Thomas
Nelson Christian encounter series jeremy
is also the editor of the new website
real clear religion Jeremy thanks for
coming thanks for having me
William F Buckley in a Christian
encounter series what's your interest in
William F Buckley my interest in William
F Buckley is that he was most more
responsible than anyone else you could
finger for founding the American
conservative movement and there was a
conservatism before Buckley various
strands and he found a way to sort of
fit them all together in this fractious
quarrelsome coalition that eventually
became a real force in American politics
his first big foray into the public
letters was gotten mad at Yale a book he
wrote when he was what 20 years old or
25 years old it was I would say it was
20 I'm guessing 25 this is part of a
your your biography which is extremely
readable and concise and the best way
possible
it's about religion what was what's the
God and man at Yale all about god Amanda
gale was William F Buckley as charged
that Yale was becoming a very secular
institution than it was abandoning its
Christian founding and that he was
making the argument that the trustees of
Yale should work to rein in what Yale
was becoming and turned it into a more
Christian institution what's the role of
religion in in national reviews brand of
conservatism well
I argue that Buckley's conservatism grew
out of his Catholicism most of the
founding editors and hangers on a
National Review were Catholic or became
Catholic it was a very very Catholic
environment it was equally Catholic and
ex-communists right yeah but many of
them became quite a few the Catholicism
people don't understand this today
because you don't have the same dynamics
and work in Catholic churches but for
instance it masked
used to be a prayer and it said in every
mass to to convert Russia and the Virgin
Mary asked for that and yeah Fatima
Catholicism was very very very hostile
to communism and I argue that that
shaped the thinking of a Buckley and
several of the other early founders of
the conservative movement and helped to
push it in a certain direction is that
the appeal of Catholicism is the idea of
a long chain of kind of historic
transhistorical institution that at
least tells its adherents that it
doesn't really change very much yeah and
one Holy Catholic and Apostolic Church
yeah let's talk about young Americans
for freedom which was founded at the
very beginning of the 60s it really kind
of mushroomed before students for a
Democratic Society
what was the why did he found g-f and
what was the role of religion in that
organization a student you know
basically a conservative student
organization yeah I mean the Buckley
viewed you have to back up a little bit
and say that Buckley viewed the the
arguments between collectivism and
individualism as essentially religious
in nature and that that gives him sort
of a libertarian push to his thinking
that will affect things later in life
and yeah is a very individualist
organization it also in their founding
documents they talk about the importance
of God and religious heritage and their
verily anti-communist right and this was
sort of the youth wing of the
conservative movement which helped to
put you know Barry Goldwater over the
top in 1964 for instance Buckley had a
pretty phenomenal sixties actually I
mean between yeah and then also running
for mayor of New York and also the
creation of firing line so you you talk
you recover the history of firing line
which was a I don't know how many years
of random must have been close to 20
years on PBS it was over 1500 episode
and I mean it's just it's a phenomenal
talk show and you talk about how it
wasn't just Buckley kind of smack
around guests but he had a wide range of
people on there and engaged them in all
sorts of ways talk a little bit about
the about how firing line came yeah it
was it originally was sort of the
precursor to crossfire it was Buckley
bloodying his liberal opponents and he
decided after a while though that was
getting boring and it just wasn't what
he wanted to do and so he broadened it
out and he would bring in other
questioners he was still the star of the
show obviously but just the the wide
range of guests is incredible I mean you
know Kurt Vonnegut Huey Newton what
about you know Buckley's race views how
does that intersect with his religious
views because he penned one of national
reviews most infamous editorials in the
late 50s talking about how the South
yeah yeah be or how the white South must
fail because blacks really weren't smart
enough at that point to vote yes
is that a Catholic belief is that a
Christian belief is that is that an
anti-communist belief of where is that
coming from he was his father was
southern and I think he put it precisely
the cultural coordinates of our
household were southern but I also want
to point out that the remedy to this was
a religious remedy and in fact he
Buckley wrote a letter to his mother
saying you know how how can we support
segregation if these blacks are our
fellow Christians how is that even
possible mm-hmm
the he penned that infamous editorial
and and that position of the magazine
lasted all of one issue it was actually
retracted in the next issue it should
have been written but the and the
arguments against it the the buzel
Marshall were constitutional but
undergirding them were moral arguments
springing from Catholicism let me let's
close by talking about real clear
religion what what is the site and what
what our goals
well it's outgrowth of real clear
politics real clear politics is the
premier political website in the United
States
here's your cheat sheet every day you
can go to see what's happening in the
world of religion as if so is it going
to be
Buddhism is up 7% this weekend you know
we will have Islam holding steady we
will have a section called religion by
the numbers yeah why is why is Obama's
religion a question of interest to
people where and actually why is it why
is his perceived Muslim Muslim ISM yeah
yeah I mean I would say that's not at
all unique to Obama people were very
interested in george w bush's religion
and a lot of people who disagree with
him vilified him for it
at the same applied to ronald reagan but
they weren't saying that Bush was a
Muslim doctor they were so they were
accused of a hard case tonight nutjob
yeah fundamentalist yeah no I mean I
think in the when people say that Barack
Obama is a Muslim there's a few possible
interpretations of this one they're just
idiots too they're saying that there's
something sort of foreign about him we
don't three the the interesting thing to
me was remember when someone said to
John McCain on the campaign trail that
you know Obama's a Muslim and he said
you know no man he's a decent man no he
and he understood the imported
what she was saying to be he's a bad
person right I don't think when a lot of
people say he's a Muslim they're saying
he's actually a Muslim I think they're
saying we don't like it right what's the
best that religion has given America as
a country and what's the worst I don't
know
sherry good feelings towards others if
you like public schools then I think
anti-catholicism was largely responsible
for that right yeah I don't know I'm the
worst just the we have a tendency to
turn everything into a moral issue you
know in Switzerland the the the job of
the tax collector is simply to extract
some amount of Taxation for the
government and you know you can
negotiate with them and it's not you
know it's not a moral thing here you
feel comfortable with those Swiss
Protestant guarding your Pope your Pope
of Rome well here's hoping you know yeah
it's amazing that that Bulgarian wasn't
able to get him you know it's sometimes
I think maybe there's there's some
divine intervention involved well if
it's gonna be for anybody I suppose it's
the Pope although as in recovering
Catholic I firmly believe what another
person in the Christian encounter books
series believed Isaac Newton and many of
the founders that the Pope was a
werewolf and an antichrist but we'll let
that go for now
I'm Nicola Lester with reason TV we've
been talking with former Reason intern
and possibly future reason intern it's a
tough economy jeremy lot who is the
author of a very interesting new book
about William F Buckley from Thomas
Nelson publisher in their Christian
encounter series and the editor of the
new website real clear religion Jeremy
thanks for coming by thanks for having
me